les villes de mantes-la-jolie élimé sont
reliés la grande passerelle qui rejoint
la place de l'étape à mantes la jolie à
proximité de la collégiale au théâtre de
verdure situé sur l'île aux dames est
désormais ouverte aux cyclistes et
piétons
ce chantier a débuté en février 2018 le
pont existant est extrêmement utilisez
donc l'idée c'était de donner plus de
place et de donner plus de place aux
sécurité donc du coup on a voulu
profiter de cette opportunité de créer
une vraie passerelle un projet attendu
depuis bien longtemps pour cet ancien
maire de mantes-la-jolie qui prévoit
également une autre passerelle en
circulation douce cette idée était née
en 1999 donc vingt ans plus tard l'avoir
réalisé c'est très important
et puis avec l'arrivée des halls sur le
territoire de menthe et plus largement
sur la vallée de seine
il est impératif qu'il y ait des
liaisons améliorée entre les deux rives
la rive droite et la rive gauche
on s'est même entendu avec le président
devedjian vous savez que nos deux
départements aspire à fusionner pour que
le long de la voie ferrée et hall entre
ouïe et dentaire il y est aussi une
passerelle en circulation douce et que
nous fidèles seront tous les deux cette
passerelle un des nouveaux éléments en
faveur de la mobilité douce finances en
majorité par la région ile de france
un coup de 9,6 millions d'euros qu'il
faut construire ces passerelles parce
qu'elles permettent là encore des
nouvelles liaisons peut-être pas en
voiture mais des liaisons 12 et liaison
vélo qui permettent de d'éviter les
embouteillages qui sont vraiment la
plaie des yvelinois et notamment le soir
et le matin à partir de février 2020
l'aide à l'achat de vélos électriques
sera proposé d'une valeur de 500 euros
pour chaque francilien